so a new trailer for Star Wars rogue one
dropped today and we all knew it was
going to drop today because we received
our little 10 second teaser preview that
got us excited about it and we probably
spent most of the day just refreshing
various feeds because what the hell else
did we have to do today right
we don't have lives let's just refresh
YouTube all fucking day but nevertheless
the trailer did drop today and it looks
damn good and this is something I
expected cuz say what you want about
Godzilla you have to admit that is a
really good looking movie and really
well directed this trailer opens with
some really beautiful wide shots showing
us this world here Forest Whitaker's
character talking about the fact that
the Empire is now ruling this area
Imperial flags are everywhere and his
trailer seems to be setting up something
that I feel is really important to make
the Star Wars movies work and that is
make the heroes feel small make them
feel vulnerable make them feel like
they're not in a position of power
because then you want to root for these
guys and we know that because we've seen
the original Star Wars movies and these
are all things we know but I'm just glad
they're setting up this world in that
way because that was something I was
concerned about are they just kind of
like assume that we know all these
things and just kind of forget to make
the movie or are they going to actually
set up this world and it seems like they
are also we do get small glimpses in
this trailer of the characters
backstories the people who are going on
this mission for the Death Star plans we
learn a little bit more about each
character one of them is recruiting for
the rebellion one of them has had their
entire home destroyed and another
character is just extremely strong in
the force and is a badass and that's
Donnie yen's character also we get to
see a little bit of the new droid in
this movie and I'm just gonna say k2 so
because that seems like that's how you
would say it voiced by Alan Tudyk
I like that he's huge and tall and
towers over everybody else but his lines
about giving odds in a terrible
situation definitely harken back to
c-3po and the Empire Strikes Back never
tell me the odds so I can't wait for
everybody to say that he's just a c-3po
copy before they even see the film
hopefully that's not the case but what
strikes me the most about this trailer
is I think what every trailer wants to
do and that is look damn good my word
Gareth Edwards vision for this film
looks beautiful I know the filmmakers
themselves have said this and other
people have said this but it's true this
really actually looks like a war
film which is something I'm really
excited about because this is Star Wars
and even though all of them have battles
and people are fighting this actually
looks like the first one that might feel
like a real war film also this film
really does seem to be setting up a
really great team a team effort that
feeling of unity and I'm truly truly
hoping that that is also in the movie
because it's really well captured in
small moments in this trailer but as we
all know what I always say trailers
don't mean shit but this one does look
really good and this movie is looking
really good and of course let's talk
about what everyone wants to report the
fact that Darth Vader is in this movie
Wow and no one knew that we all knew
that Darth Vader is in this movie but
it's certainly not stopping 17,000 news
outlets from letting us know that Darth
Vader's in this movie every two seconds
every time you load anything ever guess
what Darth Vader's in wrong one did you
guys know that Darth Vader's in rogue
one did you know that Darth Vader's
helmet is gonna be in rogue one hey look
it's the back of Darth Vader's helmet
oh shit we've never seen that before all
jokes aside it's great to hear that
breathing it's great to see the back of
that helmet but in all honesty I mean
he's been in four theatrical films we
know it talks the mater looks like at
this point I'm excited to see what kind
of dialogue he has what kind of scenes
he's given what his character actually
gets to do in this movie and I really
truly hope that he's not just some like
throwaway character they just sort of
add in like I swear if he's just in a
couple random scenes to be like hey I'm
I'm also on the Death Star
you guys have fun with your little
mission but just so you know I'm here to
alright I exist in this universe
maybe I'll get a spinoff and that's my
screen time bye bye let's just hope it's
not like that
so once again another really fun
exciting trailer for Robo one I
obviously can't wait for this movie it
looks fantastic I am really pumped for
it what did you guys think of the new
rogue one trailer let me know below and
thank you so much as always for watching
I'm gonna have reviews for sausage party
Pete's dragon and blood father coming
for you this weekend thank you once
again and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes